ce renvoi des deux irakiens à bagdad
faisait partie des reproches adressés
par le djihad islamique à la france et
justifiant selon ce mouvement
l'exécution de l'otage français michel
se rend aujourd'hui aucune information
n'a été livrée pour authentifier ou non
l'annoncé de la mort de michel sera plus
le chef le cheikh al khalili a démenti
avoir affirmé que sera était vivant une
sorte de guerre des nerfs continue donc
et nos envoyés spéciaux philippe rochot
et georges en scène ont rencontré marie
sera aujourd'hui à beyrouth
c'est pas à commenter peut-être qu'il
est vivant peut-être qu'il est membre
mais jeudi il a comparé à il ya 24
heures
je pense que les chances que michel
soient vivants sont à 75% alors après ce
démenti comment interprétez vous la
lettre le communiqué du djihad islamique
qui finalement est maintenant dépassée
alors c'est un moyen de pression c'est
c'est plus qu'un moyen de pression c'est
des menaces et moi personnellement
vivent ici depuis dix ans je sais que ce
sont des menaces qui peuvent être
exécutés peuvent les exécuter si ce
problème n'est pas résolu d'une façon ou
d'une autre il y aura une béquille
dation 2,3 à votre avis qu'est ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire et qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire maintenant je pense qu'il
faudrait parler aux ravisseurs
le gouvernement a toujours refusé de
parler avec les théories ce temps qu'il
est parce qu on lui connaît pas de
réponse mais on les connait qu'est ce
que c'est cette façon si très diffus que
mouvement semaine ce n'est pas 10 fut en
connaît un deux trois quatre
on les connaît tous ils les connaissent
tous mais il faut qu'ils leur fable il
faut qu'il faudrait qu'il le paye bon
peut-être les les revendications sont
peut-être impossibles à satisfaire
conte l'ayguade qu'on égale qu'on les
garde six mois un an mais l'essentiel
pour moi
à ce stade là c'est que michel est en
vie gouvernement français après une
réunion interministérielle à matignon a
décidé d'envoyer des émissaires pour
faire avancer les négociations ont le
tout est de savoir edward lors qu'ils
ont et comment écouter sur le premier
point qui il ne manque pas de
spécialistes en france aussi bien dans
la majorité que dans l'opposition
maintenant ce qui est plus important
c'est de savoir où et pour rencontrer
qui à teyran une délégation revient à
peine officiellement on en a parlé que
de finances en irak
il n'y a aucune chance que le
gouvernement nous rendent les deux
opposants envoyés sur bagdad
encore faut-il savoir s'ils sont
toujours en vie à damas pour quoi faire
de plus le contact est permanent avec le
président assad depuis des mois sans
résultat concret
reste évidemment beyrouth et là on se
heurte toujours au même problème avec
qui parler
et ce soir pour compliquer le tout un
communiqué du hezbollah qui lie la
sécurité des français au départ de
françois mitterrand
ça n'arrange rien alors la femme de
michel seurat disais tout à l'heure que
l'on avait perdu beaucoup de temps
depuis neuf mois et demi et que l'on a
commis beaucoup d'erreurs
effectivement neuf mois et demi c'est
long pour se trouver là on se trouve
aujourd'hui
alors on peut se poser des questions sur
ce qu'on a fait ou ce qu'on n'a pas fait
si le gouvernement français ne s'est pas
trompé de cible en accordant les
négociations comme s'il s'agissait d'un
accord diplomatique en essayant de faire
plaisir à tout le monde
les irakiens les iraniens damas et
surtout et c'est peut-être la plus
grosse erreur en oubliant à qui on a
affaire à des fanatiques
résultat aujourd'hui ils ont renversé la
vapeur ce sont eux qui tiennent entre
leurs mains et les otages et le
gouvernement français oui à paris en mai